okay today I'm going to show you how to
complete a titration calculation so
going to have a quick recap about what a
titration is and then we're going to see
how we could use it to find the
concentration of an acid so quick recap
first of all so here is the equipment
for a titration we have a burette and a
conical flask so the burette job is to
slowly return this tap and little by
little we allow acid to fall down into
my alkaline this is this type of
reaction is a neutralization reaction
because we've got an acid reacting with
an alkali to produce salt and water the
very very second that this solution is
neutralized we will have an instant
color change so my indicator will change
color and I will know exactly how much
acid was required to neutralize this so
in this experiment I have made this
solution here I've made this up myself
so I know exactly the volume of this
solution I've made and I've deliberately
controlled the concentration I've made
this so I know the concentration of my
alkaline the whole purpose of what we're
doing is we're trying to find the
concentration of this acid because we
know exactly 25 cents minutes cubed of
this acid was required to neutralize
this alkali but we don't know the
concentration of the acid so the whole
point is to find the concentration of
the acid so the first first thing you
need to do is write the balance symbol
equation which I've got right here so
soft furyk acid plus sodium hydroxide
goes to the sodium sulfate plus water
right the next thing that I'm going to
do is I'm just going to write down the
information from my experiment
underneath each part so I've got 25
centimeters cubed of that and I've got
20 centimeters cubed of this and I've
also got 0.2 moles per decimeter cubed
of sodium hydroxide as well so I've got
a volume and a and a concentration for
this one for this one I only know a
volume at the moment so remember the
whole point is I'm trying to find the
concentration of this but I can't do it
straight away and we'll see
in a second so the first thing we need
to do whenever we're dealing with
titrations we need to convert
centimeters cubes into decimeters cubed
so to do that I need to do need to
divide by a thousand so 25 divided by a
thousand equals 0.025 decimeters cute
and 20 so this one I'm converting as
well 20 divided by a thousand equals
0.02 decimetres cubed so I'm just going
to update these that's decimetres queued
and this is zero point zero two zero
decimeters cubed okay now I've converted
it because whenever we deal with
titrations we need these units to be in
decimeters cubed right now what I need
to do next is at the moment well I'm
going to use this equation triangle
basically so my equation triangle right
here my equation triangle right here
looks like this I have n C times V n
stands for number of moles C stands for
concentration and V stands for volume
now remember what number of moles means
is just the number of molecules that are
reacting with in a particular experiment
concentration and the volume we have
right here so the reason why I can't
find the concentration of this yet is in
order to see where I use an equation
triangle I need two of the three parts
and the moment I only have the volume so
to find the concentration I need to find
the number of moles of this now this is
the clever part first of all I need to
find the number of moles of my sodium
hydroxide so to do that all I need to do
is I cover up my end because I'm trying
to find the number of moles so I need to
do concentration times volume so I'm
gonna use these numbers here so to find
my number of moles so remember that's
just the number of molecules reacting in
this experiment I need to do my
concentration which is zero
point two miles per decimeter cubed and
multiply it by my volume which is here
zero point zero two decimeters cubed
well so let's have a look so I do zero
point two times zero point zero two and
my answer is zero point zero zero four
so that's the number of moles reacting
the number of moles of sodium hydroxide
so I'm just going to add that bit of
information under here to help me out
zero point zero zero four
now here's the really clever bit because
what we need to do next is find the
molar ratio so I'm looking at my my
symbol equation and I'm looking at the
ratio of sulfuric acid molecules to
sodium hydroxide molecules as I can see
for every one one mole I say every mop
one molecule of sulfuric acid reacts
with two molecules of sodium hydroxide
so my molar ratio is one to two because
one my molecule of that reacts with two
molecules of that so I now can find my
number of moles of base because if the
the number of moles of sodium hydroxide
is 0.004 to find out because it's a one
to two ratio to find the number of moles
of sulfuric acid I need to divide this
by two so I'm going to do zero point
zero zero four divided by two which
equals zero point zero zero two so that
there is my number of moles so I'm going
to write this up here zero point zero
zero two so you can now see now I've got
my volume and my number of moles of my
sulfuric acid so now I can use this
equation because I've now got two parts
that I need to find my concentration
so my concentration all I need to do is
cover up my C
so I need to do n divided by V so my
concentration equals my number of moles
which is this I've managed to find from
my molar ratio which is zero point zero
zero two and dividing by my volume my
volume is here divided by zero point
zero two five and then I just need to
put that into my calculator zero point
zero zero two divided by zero point zero
two five equals the answer is zero point
zero eight and it because it's
concentration my units are moles per
decimeter cubed so just to recap first
thing that you need to do is write down
your information you then need to
convert everything to decimeters cubed
you could then find the number of moles
of soap that reacted of sodium hydroxide
then by looking at the symbol equation
you need to find the molar ratio from
the molar ratio you could figure out the
number of moles of sulfuric acid that
reacted and the final step is to use
this equation again to find the
concentration of the acid because that's
what we set out to do in the first place
thank you very much